so how much of you did you bring to this
character about 95% of myself with the
help of spike of course he allowed me to
well have significant input I didn't
realize it at the time but many of the
actors were given the opportunity to
bring a lot of themselves to their
character Barozzi I'm sure did I I'm
quite sure Bilbo
and I I thought it made for a very happy
set and a lot of happy actors I thought
it might be difficult most screenplay
writers you get with a little reluctant
to allow themselves to to allow that
kind of thing to occur but early on at
the beginning I I didn't realize that
spike would be this way incidentally I I
was seventeen when we started shooting
this movie I just looked a lot older
than I and it was a great experience
however I didn't realize it was a
political thriller when we were making
it you know spike said to me just said a
couple of moments ago that the American
public knew we were telling the truth
and I truly and I truly think that the
reason they reacted positively for this
film was because Spike made a wonderful
film that's right thank you
there are all sorts of messages in it
because as you know I am the Jackie
Robinson of the black films I mean along
with this one I did howl of nights as
well right after this so you are
introduced in this film
how are you discovered long story short
in go to a nightclub I didn't know it
was his birthday he was having a butt
contest to see which black woman in the
club had the biggest is what all the
song doing the but no the button okay
the but what movie was that school bass
was that that not that number-one R&B
song at the time yes thank you this is
what I had to deal with so so I get on
the speaker to to mock the whole thing
and on everything and then these bounces
come over and tell me to get down and he
was there and and he we got in an
argument and he kept laughing at me
while I was cursing him out and he asked
me where I was from and I said Brooklyn
and he started laughing at me and I
cursed him out again and and then he
said tonight his fate and that was it so
so was it the butt or the accident
did you wasn't my ear so my accent that
would you advocate me no and you went to
college for this all right I'm gonna
tell y'all a secret about the whole you
know right after we did this film I did
a couple other films like Sister Act and
I was playing this older guy and people
were like writing me talking about it
damn how did you get so old so fast
I was actually old when I did do the
right thing so I was not this young
black kid from Brooklyn really I was a
35 year old from Atlanta who came up to
Brooklyn to make this movie with Spike
so that was the secret you know of me
capturing young black manhood I was
faking it man aren't we all do you carry
you literally carry the weight of
politically conscious socially conscious
rap there's you have you carried that
after this film into a period of hip-hop
that represented perhaps its golden age
that people come to equate you with
Public Enemy and fight the power well
I've gotten out of a lot of ass-whipping
zone over the years I can basically hang
out in any community all over Brooklyn
when Decepticons were back in the day
they would be hey man it's you you know
so it has been great and and that era of
hip-hop to me has never been touched I
still thank you I still listen to all
the old stuff I'm not crazy about the
new stuff but I'm like 60 something now
so I'm still at least I'm still
listening to hip-hop
and my 60s it's in its 40th the air
hip-hop is middle-aged if you didn't
know it but you you are evil incarnate
in this film yes this is one of my first
films and then I went back to California
I was living there and people were mad
at me I mean they were brothers in the
industry telling me you killed radio
right neither James I had to change my
phone number I'll tell you what it's
when I was doing it like it was my for
my first things and I didn't think much
of it but I did I do remember it was
like a family we had a great time and it
was great
I never wasn't fear of anything I was
well I mean it was just a great
experience and look at this 25 years
later we're still talking about it's
amazing it's great to be part now now
this may sound of inappropriate question
but I can't help but ask it so one of
the things that the black folks
fantasize about is being a fly on the
wall and white people are amongst
themselves did you ever get the
high-five from an NYPD officer or any
other police officers like you know I
you know because you you've described
what the brother said to you but but
tell us if you ever had a moment where
someone said you know you did the right
thing
should I interrupt the moment I did put
Apache the Bronx I truly for tarika know
if the roof I got all sorts of - that's
not a discriminating thing it just
actually occurred I'm sorry but I'm
gonna be honest we were there
differently on bang I'm gonna be honest
with you I have never seen or heard any
white person come to me say good job
that's good
that's actually reassuring although a
lot of bad things still happen